6 26 on your monday morning what's  driving you crazy folks not doing the  right thing around  emergencies got a complaint from someone  who would know  spencer wrote it hey when you see a fire  truck ambulance police vehicle or a tow  truck at a scene  move over he writes so many times i've  been almost  clipped cleaning a scene i've seen cars  and trucks barely miss  officers firefighters emts and my fellow  wrecker operators  he continues get off the phone take a  moment to slow down  to move over one lane we all want to go  home at the end of the day  glad to help spread the word spencer  stay safe and this certainly applies  when emergency responders are rolling  code the law is clear  if lights and sirens are coming up  behind you get over to the right as  quickly and safely as possible  buckle up drive carefully please put on  that phone if there's something driving  you crazy email me  traffic 8 8 news now dot com